[MUSIC PLAYING]
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Perfect.
All right, welcome
to Talks at Google.
I'm Dominique Ehrl.
I'm sure I've met
most of you here.
I'm here with the executive
director of the Hispanic Latino
Commission of Michigan,
Dr. Felipe Lopez Sustaita,
to share his story of the
immigrant worker experience,
"From the Fields to the
Michigan State Capitol."
Let's please give him
a big Google welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
FELIPE LOPEZ
SUSTAITA: Thank you.
Thank you, Dominique.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Of course.
And it really wouldn't
be a true Google
welcome without an icebreaker.
So I'd love to kick it
off with asking you,
as a second generation Latina
myself living in the US,
I feel there is a
certain obligation
to keep my Latinidad alive,
whether that be speaking
Spanish, teaching others
about my identity,
dancing, advocating for
the community, et cetera,
or even carrying out traditions,
and with the Day of the Dead
just recently finishing
the last few days,
can you talk to us about maybe
one of your favorite family
traditions that you carry out
to keep your culture alive?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA: Yes.
So family traditions, I
always think of Christmas.
We were so poor that--
tamales, right?
So you unwrapped
something the next day,
so we didn't have
actual presents.
But the tamales was
always a good sign
that we were doing good.
We might not have gotten the Air
Jordans or the beautiful things
that we could have dreamed
of, but we had tamales.
And it's something
that my mom still does,
and it's a tradition that
makes me remember of--
And still, even today, that's
still the most important thing.
So thank you, yeah, for
embracing the Day of the Dead.
And it's just part
of our culture,
being Latino, Latina,
in this country.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Absolutely.
Thank you.
Great.
So I'd love to dive right
into the topic for here
today by going back to the
beginning of your story,
before you accomplished
your career
and your multiple degrees
that you've received.
Can you tell us
about your childhood
and how you became a part of
the migrant worker community
in the United States?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA: Yes.
And I just want to acknowledge,
too, I want to thank Dominique.
I was a keynote speaker
for Cesar Chavez, who
is a legend and an
advocate for Latinos,
and we were at Eastern
Michigan University.
There was about 500 people.
And that day, I just
felt the Holy Spirit.
I felt that I had a mission
to go there and inspire
some of the young
people from all
over the state, young people.
And so I want to acknowledge,
so thank you very much
for making this happen
and for being there,
and for Google to be so
involved with a community
that you happen to
be there that day.
So going back, I was born in
Matehuala, San Luis Potosí,
Mexico, as the youngest of 12
really, but eight of us lived.
And we lived in poverty.
We grew up poor.
But I was raised here in the US.
I came to this country.
And luckily, my father was a
Bracero back in World War II.
When the men, American
men, were going to war,
they brought in Mexican men
to work in the agriculture.
And so that was our first
glimpse of how we even
ended up in the US.
It was through that journey
that brought us to America.
And so my journey began
since I can remember.
My entire childhood was
working in the fields.
And I don't know how, but all
of the people in my village
would move around.
We'd move around.
We would go to Tennessee,
Georgia, Michigan,
and we picked everything
from onions to oranges.
And in Tennessee,
we planted tobacco.
We picked strawberries
and onions in Georgia
and then up in Michigan.
So that's how it started.
In this country, if you
don't have education,
I mean, the fields
is a good place.
And that's how I started.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Great.
Thank you.
So can you give us some context,
as somebody who has lived,
what it means to be
a migrant worker?
Who is a migrant worker?
And how do they get here
to the United States?
Why did they come?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA: Yeah.
So migrant workers,
there's different types
of migrant workers.
You have first generation,
second, third generation.
Sometimes migrants,
that's just a way of life.
They've been here
five, six generations.
I don't know if they enjoy it,
or if they don't know anything
better.
But for us, I can tell you
that it was really hard.
I mean, I always tell this story
when I talk to the young people
that I slept on the floor.
I mean, being the
youngest of eight,
sometimes a room was as big as a
classroom in a college setting,
like just half of the room,
and eight of us lived there.
And so I was the youngest
one, so I knew my role.
It was sleeping on the floor all
the way till I came to college.
And then just the poverty
that goes with it,
like the long hours.
I remember when I was 12
years old, 11 years old
is when I started working
16- or 18-hour shifts.
And that's why the office
that I'm in is so important.
It's to regulate those laws
that young people shouldn't
be working that long.
But a migrant is just somebody
that moves from state to state,
or maybe they're seasonal.
They live here in
Michigan, maybe they just
pick during the season.
And they come from
all over the place.
They don't just look like me.
There's a big
population of Haitians
that are coming now
to the US, and it's
being used as a major force
now, the Haitian community.
And then obviously,
the Mexican community
has been along for very long,
since before Cesar Chavez
and Dolores Huerta.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Great.
Thank you.
And do you mind giving
us a quick recap on who
Cesar Chavez was for
those of us who may not
have heard of him before?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA: Yeah.
So Cesar Chavez,
he was a veteran.
He was born in Arizona.
He went to the military.
I think his family went through
a financial crisis, kind
of similar to what it's now,
and that took him and his family
into working in the fields.
And that's when he
saw firsthand how
the inequalities of migrant
workers, how they were being
brought in and
weren't being paid
or weren't being paid enough or
living in terrible conditions.
So he really fought.
And he fought in a very quiet--
very similar to Dr.
Martin Luther King.
He didn't fight with his fists.
He fought with his mind
and his humbleness.
And I think that's what we can
remind him of a fighter that
fought for his people.
Very kind.
And that's who Cesar Chavez was.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Great.
Thank you.
So although invisible
to most people,
the presence of migrant workers
in many rural communities
throughout the
nation is undeniable.
Since hand labor is a
necessary for production
of blemish free fruits and
vegetables that consumers
demand, why are
they so invisible?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA:
So the invisibility,
I think it's intentional.
So like I said, I've moved
around in different cities.
And in Tennessee, we were
very hidden from everywhere.
I think in this country,
we want to eat our salads,
we want to eat our
oranges or apples,
but yet, we're hidden in
some of the communities.
Maybe it's because of zoning, or
maybe it's for whatever reason.
Maybe there's this
perception that the property
loses value when we're
there, whatever it is.
But we do tend to be almost
hidden in some cities, almost
invisible.
We come out on
Sunday to do laundry.
And in some cities, people go
wild on Facebook or Twitter
like, oh, all these Mexicans
are shopping at Meijer.
And I hear those
stories constantly
traveling through the state
of people that are unaware.
Yet, they don't realize that
we're the ones providing
the food so that people eat.
So it's a very
interesting dichotomy
that that's happening.
But yeah, I have two
brothers, one of them
that recently stopped working.
He got injured.
And he had been working
his entire life.
And then I have another one
that was still picking apples.
And nothing has changed.
It's been, I don't know--
I'm 34 years old,
since I was little.
And they always pick somebody
else to come and do the work,
so it hasn't changed a lot.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Thank you.
So it's a great paradox
of our food system
that the very people who
work to feed the US struggle
to feed their own families.
Farm workers are among the
poorest workers in the country.
Child farm workers risk their
safety, health, and education
working for fields because their
parents can't earn a living
wage.
Hazardous conditions
are routine,
as I'm sure you're
familiar with,
including pesticide exposure,
extreme heat, lack of shade,
and sometimes inadequate
drinking water.
Did you ever witness or hear
of any of these conditions?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA: Yes.
And again, this was in the
middle of the 90s, early 90s,
when I was first exposed.
And I remember as a child
playing through the fields,
and the airplanes would
come and pesticide.
And so I'm sure I was exposed.
And it's heartbreaking
thinking back of pregnant women
out there working and the
children and the effects
that it had.
My father, he passed
away when he was 62.
So I was 17 years old
when he passed away.
And I know it's because
of the intense work
labor, the intense hours.
I'm sure that I would pass away,
too, if I continue to work 16,
17 hours shifts my entire life.
And so I've experienced,
like I said,
the housing-- there was snakes
sometimes that we would kill.
And no child-- I'm sure
my parents didn't--
they had a hard time
grasping with that.
But that has been
generations of poverty.
I don't know how they grew up.
And for me, it was
probably a great living.
Even if there was
snakes or we were
in a part of a barn
sleeping, it was a lot better
than it was in Mexico.
So there is still work
that needs to be done.
I remember, I mean, the trailer
we lived in Covert, Michigan--
and my brother
still lives there--
I remember not having
running hot water.
And the one year we stayed,
it was October, November,
December, I had to boil
water before I go to school
and just took it in.
And we didn't have no
heater, and everybody
slept in the floor to
be close to the heater,
the kerosene heater.
And so those things
are still here.
I'm sure there's kids still
sleeping in the floor,
the housing's still
no running water.
I had to go out into an
outhouse to go to the bathroom
and shower outside of the house.
They didn't have that.
This was, again, in my lifetime,
and I'm only 34 years old.
So I know that it's
still out there.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Thank
you for sharing.
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA:
Oh, no problem.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: So I'm curious--
you spoke a little
bit about maybe
how your parents might
have been feeling.
And I'm sure as all of us have
been children at one point,
and there's things
that are covered up
that our parents tried
to make things better,
especially when situations
maybe aren't as good
or what they would
hope them to be.
Can you speak a little
bit to maybe your family
or other families'
experiences with morale?
That's something that I was
curious about when researching
about migrant workers.
Are people optimistic?
Are they complacent?
What is the sentiment
around their situation?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA: So
for us, it was always prayer.
[SPEAKING SPANISH] God.
My parents had so much faith.
And I think that's where
my sense of being--
that's what carried us
through, this energy,
this positive energy that
things would work out.
And so I was always blessed
leaving the house or in
[SPEAKING SPANISH],, and
that's a constant reminder
that there's hope.
And for us as Catholics,
that was something
that I think allowed us to
survive because it was really--
I can't imagine if
I was barely eating,
I don't know if they
were eating at all.
And so when you think of that,
I remember the corn flakes
with water and
mixing coffee powder
to make milk or Valentina--
all the Latinos always had
Valentina-- with salt crackers.
And I remember those
meals, so I can't
imagine if I was going through
that, what my parents were
struggling with.
I had a brother who
also passed away at 43,
and I believe it was because
of the hard life of working
and the pesticides and all this.
And he passed away at 43.
But he was the
life of our family.
He was a happy guy, Ismael.
I always think of him
because he was just so happy.
When I was listening to the
Google with George Lopez,
you always have somebody in the
family that just brings joy.
And Ismael was the one.
He was always cracking
jokes, no matter if it
was a snake that they cut and he
was trying to scare other kids.
But he had that
sense of happiness.
And to an extent, I
think it prepared me
for going to get a
doctorate degree.
There's no way I
could have made it
if I didn't have those struggles
of hoeing or picking something
or asparagus and looking at the
long lines and thinking, man,
can I make it
through those lines?
It taught me self-discipline,
to stay in my lane
and stay focused on
finishing whatever that was.
But I think faith, if I were
to say, that carried us.
I think that was the
game changer, the faith.
And that we still have.
I talk to my mother
every single day.
And this morning,
I talked to her.
I said, Mom, pray for me.
And it's something that I feel
like it's like a shield for me.
And respecting other
cultures because I
have a lot of friends that
are from other cultures,
and I also respect that as well.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Great.
Thank you.
I've also always admired--
I'm not sure if it's just
with Latinos or people that
maybe are underrepresented
or other minority groups--
the sense of happiness,
even when there's nothing.
I've witnessed that myself
with my family in Mexico, too.
And it's just a really
great reminder and gut
check of like, you know,
things aren't so bad.
And not to say that
someone's situation
is worse or better than someone
else's, but in hindsight,
all of us here are in
a place of privilege.
And it's always a good
reminder to kind of go back
to where our roots are
from in certain situations.
So thank you.
So what you were kind of
talking about at the end there,
I think, pivots to my
next question for you.
Sometimes even the
thought of pursuing
an education for many
marginalized communities
can often be seen as foreign,
impossible, laughable,
or just it's not going
to happen for you.
So what was your out?
What was your driver?
How did you make
it into college?
FELIPE LOPEZ
SUSTAITA: So for me,
it's going to be a little
bit of a longer story.
But it's important because
I got to pay respect
to the folks that have allowed
me this privilege of being
in Google, for all you know.
Never in my life
did I ever imagine
that I'd be here with your
folks listening to this tape.
We're very traditional,
especially with women.
Latina women have it, I
think, way harder than we do.
And my sisters,
all four of them,
are tough, strong Latinas,
and my mother, of course,
we have to look up.
But my sister Mayra,
she was the first one
who came to Michigan State, and
it was through night school.
We went to night
school that one time.
And I was like 13 years
old-- the only time--
and that was to make
up credits so that I
could graduate in three years.
We met this gentleman
named Rudy Hernandez, who's
from southwest Detroit,
who really set the tone.
And Mayra was smart enough
to get into Michigan State,
and so that's how
it all started.
Mayra was accepted.
She, in her mind,
made this pledge
that she was going to get
out of that lifestyle.
Because it is terrible when
you're out in the dirty
all the time and not making
any money and just at home.
And so she went to college.
And it was because of Rudy
that gave her that opportunity.
And again, I believe it's faith.
It's Rudy was there that night.
If Rudy wasn't
there that night, I
don't know if we would
have been here right now.
But Rudy was there, met Mayra.
And Rudy was one of
these educators--
I love higher ed
people, especially when
they go out of their way.
Rudy went and asked my parents
if they could allow Mayra
to come to Michigan State.
And they didn't really want to,
but they didn't have a choice.
So they said [SPEAKING SPANISH].
That's something that Latinos--
once they say that, it's a gold.
Like, go.
Right?
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
And so they did.
And that's when
my journey began.
Basically, I didn't
have a choice.
My parents were like, you
got to go take care of Mayra.
Not that Mayra needed
me to take care of her,
but that's how the
Latino mindset is.
And so I ended up with a 13.
I thought it was a 13 on my ACT.
We checked, my wife checked,
and she said I got a 15.
So I couldn't even read
correctly that I got a 15.
And I'll be honest
with you, again,
it was because of Rudy I got
admitted to Michigan State.
But I took the test a few
days before admissions,
and I guessed on everything.
But again, I was blessed
that it came with a package.
You accept Mayra, you're
going to accept Felipe.
And so I came in.
I couldn't read,
I couldn't write.
When you're a migrant
worker, you leave.
In October, you
leave the school,
and then you leave to
go back home to Texas.
And then you leave early,
you leave in March.
And so you're always
making up work.
And so oftentimes,
that's a blessing, too,
because they didn't really
pay attention if I was failing
or not.
I was always passed.
But the unfortunate part is
that I couldn't read or write.
I didn't know my ABCs.
But I was very clever
and very smart.
I made up credits.
My sister was helping
me do my math homework.
I passed, and the
rest was history.
I came to Michigan State.
A lot of tragedies happened.
Like I said, my father passed
away my sophomore year.
My brother passed.
And so there was a
lot of tragedies.
But I can always look back,
and that's a motivation,
that people out there
are really good people.
The person that I
least expected came in
and gave us this opportunity.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Wonderful.
Thank you.
So for many first generation
students, and minorities
in general, it's one
thing to get into college,
and then to be accepted, all of
that which is the first step.
But there is still a
large gap for completion
of higher education.
Now you've received two degrees,
two bachelors, I believe,
as well as a doctorate.
Can you talk about what drove
you to finish not only one,
but multiple degrees?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA: Yeah.
So like I said,
it takes a village
to do this kind of work.
And I met a lot of great people.
One of my friends, Juan
Flores, who came with us,
we were in remedial math.
We didn't even make it to
the real classes, right?
So we were remedial
math, remedial writing,
everything was remedial.
And I could barely
pass those classes.
But I've had Juan, I've
had other great people.
My sister Mayra was there.
I was very antisocial,
too, because of everything
that I mentioned, all the
stigma that happens in school.
But I've had good
people, and I've
met great people along the way.
My friend Kelly Simmons,
who I met through Mayra
working in the KCP programs.
I met my friend Danny,
who's here also with me.
We met in Greece and
have stayed in touch.
And I met great people
like Sean Smith,
Daniel [INAUDIBLE],, who
works with me in the office,
and Sean, who has had a vision
to help students get out
of the math and graduate.
And my wife.
So there's been
a lot of pieces--
my family, obviously--
that have been supportive.
But the biggest
thing is that I've
had this vision, like
this law of attraction,
that if you think positive--
I always think of
my brother Ismael
because sometimes money would
just show up out of nowhere,
and I would say, man,
how do you do that?
He didn't go to
school or anything.
He didn't even
finish high school.
He dropped out.
But he had such a positive
vibe that the people that
would come, everything that
he had was just his thinking.
He was so positive.
And so I started applying
that, just being so positive
and studying the law of
attraction and vision boards,
and everything
that I said that--
And people would laugh, right?
It's laughable.
Oh, you're going
to do this, you're
going to do that,
it's laughable.
But it's happened
because of that.
I was already signing doctor
when I was with Danny.
We were in Hungary, and I was
writing postcards to my sister,
writing Doctor Felipe
Lopez Sustaita.
And I was barely trying to get
through my bachelor's degree,
but I was already envisioning
that I was going to get there.
And so it's almost like
it's already happened
and it's not there yet.
But I keep talking
about my goals.
And sometimes I
get flagged for it,
like, oh, you think you're so
good or [SPEAKING SPANISH]..
It's not that.
It's just that sometimes we
need positive role models.
So that's why I
really appreciate
you allowing me this platform
because that's what it takes.
Sometimes we have to
put it out there and say
that if we're going to
conquer the world, right,
we have to talk
about it and do it.
And it doesn't mean
that it wasn't hard.
I mean, academically, if you can
go from not reading or writing,
being able to, to
finishing in four years,
it took a lot of hard work.
Going on study abroads--
I went to Greece, I
went to Ghana in Africa,
I went to Ukraine,
and then in Mexico--
to make up credits so that
I could graduate early.
And I was able to get out
in four, so by the time
I was 20 years old.
And then I did my masters by 22.
And then I had a
family, and then I
went and got my doctorate.
And I got it all paid for,
all my masters, my doctorate
degree.
And again, things
just don't happen.
I had it already written
that it was going to be paid
and that this was
going to happen.
And again, there's
so many things
that I'm sure I'm missing.
And especially the rigor of
the classroom and teachers
telling me just to quit.
And I remember--
I won't put names out there--
but I've been told, just stop,
you're not going
to pass a class.
And I refused.
And I think it's that
ignorance that has brought me
this far, the ignorance
to accept where you're at
and to just say no, why not?
If you can do it-- if
I see other people,
if they can do it, why can't I?
And so that attitude.
And I'll tell you one last story
before we go to the next thing.
So I remember my senior
year, I was 16 years old.
I was in Covert, Michigan.
And again, I couldn't
read or write.
So my teacher gave
me an assessment.
And I remember it vividly.
She sat down with me and
gave me this assessment.
And she told me, she's like,
you're at a third grade level.
There's no way.
I mean, even my kids now
can spell better than I can.
And so if I would have
taken that literally,
there was no way that I
would have ever made it even
to graduate high school.
But I was too ignorant
to know what that meant.
And I'm very thankful
for that ignorance
as well because it's helped me
through other difficult times.
So yeah, I mean,
part of it is luck.
A lot of luck and hard work.
Yeah.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: So on
this note of people
coming into your life that
gave you an opportunity
or maybe being a
little bit lucky
and having that grit to
continue despite the challenges,
there is a lot of people
who, despite maybe
having the same outlook,
still don't make it.
Is there a clear distinction
between those who kind of make
it out versus those who don't?
I mean, is there a big
difference that you know of?
I'm curious more than
anything to know.
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA: That's
a really, really, really good
question because I've met
some very successful people.
I'm thinking of a good friend
of mine that migrant as well,
ended up going to
Philadelphia to college,
and then ended up going to
get her PhD in Stanford.
Out of the same place.
There's no difference between.
If you're a migrant,
you're a migrant.
And then I've met
others that have
gone on to work with
the governor of Michigan
and being their chief of
staff and have worked for two,
three different governments.
Same circumstances, but
they had that extra.
And Elva says it
all the time, she
says I'm made out of titanium.
Ice nor fire can take me down.
I've been through the ringers.
And so it's that extra step.
It's that swagger.
I mean, if you can
go through that,
what I just told you, just
being so much in poverty
and you can survive, and then
moving from place to place.
I think of my parents moving
from their entire family
and not speaking
the language, not
having a salary, nothing,
to bringing us here
and then making us
and be successful,
I think they're people
that don't quit.
Because I've thought about that,
too, because I think of Mayra.
She works for the Border
Patrol, and she ended up
going to Washington DC and
doing very important work
that she was doing.
And so I often think of that.
But I think really it goes
back to-- at least for me
and the people that I know-- is
my family, and then our faith.
We have faith that things
will work out, no matter what,
how hard it gets.
And I've always said
this-- you're going
to have to drag me lout dead.
I'm not leaving this place until
I finish what I came to do.
And I get that from
my dad as well.
There was no quit ever.
But I think there is something.
It's that titanium, and
I guess that's the way
we're going to put it, right?
If you're built out
of titanium, then you
can go through anything.
Fire, ice, snow, and nothing's
going to pull you apart.
And so that's the
way I would say.
It's like NASA, right?
They went up.
Who would have
thought that somebody
would have ended up in space?
And somebody dreamed big.
Maybe they were told,
no, you can't do this.
But they refused to dream big.
And I think that's
how I see myself, too.
And I often tell young people
that I talked to-- we're just
getting started.
And no matter what--
and I tell my kids--
if you want to be
president of the US,
say it, speak it, and
then let's go get it.
I don't want excuses.
I don't care if you fall and
you're broken into 100 pieces.
You put yourself back
and you go and get it.
And so that's just the attitude.
I think that I learned from all
my siblings, all eight of them,
who taught me lessons.
And they built titanium, right?
That's what I made out of,
and that's exactly how I feel.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Beautiful.
Thank you.
So can you tell us a little
bit about how you ended up
in a career in
government here working
with the Hispanic Latino
Commission of Michigan,
what your role is also as
the executive director?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA: Yes.
That's an excellent question.
I always ask myself
that as well.
Because I went into
higher education, so
I did an undergrad
in criminal justice.
Then I did a master's
in clinical social work,
and then I did a
doctorate in education.
And I've worked as a therapist.
I've worked as an
academic advisor.
I've taught.
And then I end up in
government, not really
knowing why or how or how
that even happens, right?
It's like a puzzle.
But I've always said this--
and I constantly say this
to my kids and to my friends--
is that I work for God,
and so there's probably
a reason why I'm here.
And I came at a
very critical time.
In 2016 is when I started.
And the Latino community
is very crucial.
With everything going on, I
think I was built, like I said,
out of titanium to take the
roles that are going on,
the issue that we
have with education,
the issue that we have with
businesses, with immigration.
And if anybody was
tested to get there,
I felt like it was a
privilege and an honor
for me, especially
coming into this country
and being undocumented
and understanding
the migrant fields
to a certain extent the
hoods because I grew up
in the barrio.
That's the other piece that
I haven't talked about,
but growing up in a
barrio is rough, too.
It's filled with gangs
and filled with drugs.
Luckily, I never got
involved with any of that.
Mine was petty.
It was just hanging
out with people
and maybe fighting in
school here and there.
But it was never big time, so
I never really talk about it.
But if anybody was prepared
to take on this role,
I felt like it was God
putting me in this position
to go and do it.
And so this position,
what it entails
is advising the governor,
advising the legislature,
and then advising the state
departments on Latino issues.
So I travel all over the state.
I've put in about close to
35,000 miles going from city
to city with the most
vulnerable people.
And again, that's a
craft, to be able to go
with the most vulnerable
people and sit
with them in their homes.
And even for them to allow
me to come into their homes
has been a huge
deal because that's
the only way I can
advise the governor
and the legislature is
to let them know, look,
these are real stories.
And I can name names, I can
name places where I'm at.
So I think I serve as a
linkage to what I'm doing.
And so it's very
complicated work,
but I feel like I'm growing
and learning for something
that whatever's coming next.
And so that's really
what the job entails,
and that's how I ended up.
It was never planned.
It was never something
that I thought of.
My plan, after I got my
doctorate in community college
leadership, was going for the
presidency, for a community
college presidency.
And that's another one that
people sometimes laugh.
They're like, oh,
that's impossible.
Oh, it's not impossible.
I did my dissertation,
and I went and visited
these people that have done it.
And I did my homework, right?
So you figure out how
other people did it,
and then you go back and
then you start working.
It's like a lab.
And that's what I did.
I did my dissertation.
I interviewed all these
successful people.
I came back and
built my own recipe.
And mine has looked different.
I came to government.
Others have gone directly
through the pipeline.
And very fortunate--
I met a Latina
that became a president at 33.
And those are the kind of
people who are out there.
And I talked to her, I
listened to her story,
and then go back
and get to work.
Again, it's a lab,
a never-ending lab.
And that's what has been helpful
is also to use my resources
and then to apply them and
be the best at what we do.
I know that's a long answer.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: No,
they're great answers.
Thank you.
So you spoke a little
bit about how you
connect with these communities.
We do a lot of diversity and
inclusion work here at Google.
So all the employee
resource groups
that we have usually
have like a pillar that
owns community impact.
How do you go into
these communities
as someone who might
seem as a person in power
and connect with them?
Are there strategies
that you have?
How do you best
really get to the core
and become a trusted person
to these communities?
FELIPE LOPEZ
SUSTAITA: Yeah, that's
an excellent question because
you can't teach being humble.
That's the first step
in whatever community.
Whether it's a Jewish
community, whether it's
a Latino community, the
Caucasian community,
you got to come in
knowing your place.
You have to be humble.
And when I go into
these communities--
Because, again, I'm like
cold switching all the time.
I could be going to
a predominantly black
neighborhood, but still
representing the Latino
community for alliances, and
with the Jewish community,
the Latino community,
just alliances.
So the first thing
is humble, knowing
that I'm not better
than everybody
or that I'm not anything.
Our community is
very hard to crack.
And so especially with
the times right now,
people don't trust
people if you come in.
Even if you're going for voting,
they won't open the door.
I still don't open my door.
I'm still not 100% secure.
And meeting people
where they are.
Sometimes I go to a factory,
or I'll go to the schools
and make myself visible.
But the best thing
for me has been
to go with a trusted
person in the community.
I don't have the time to be that
person to go to, I don't know,
Alpena 20 times from Lansing.
I don't have that, so I
have to do my research
and figure out who is a person
that's the most trusted,
make that connection.
And my job is to make sure
that we have a connection
right there because if they
don't open their doors,
nobody is going to
open the doors to me.
So that's how I've
been doing it.
Whether it's Flint,
whether it's Detroit,
whether it's Benton
Harbor, I have
to go with a trusted person.
That's how they
sponsor me, right?
So Google now.
It's like Google.
If I go to another
city, like California,
and I go and ask for
something, maybe I've
done something with them and
did good by my word, that
is very helpful.
And so that's how I've done it
is through understanding who
the real champion
of the community is
and then going there after that.
Then it's up to me.
I literally sometimes
have 30 seconds
to make a connection
with these folks.
And my ability to speak Spanish
has helped tremendously.
And my ability that I was
born in another country
and I understand the fear
that you have or what you do,
that gives me more
brownie points, too.
And I never abuse that.
I never take that for granted.
I understand that that's
personal and private,
and that's how I operate.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Great.
Thank you.
So I'm going to end off
on one last question,
and then we'll hand it
over to the audience
for some live Q&A. What sense
of responsibility do you feel?
Often-- I can speak
for myself, too--
my parents' conditions
are not what I have today.
I think that's true for many
immigrant second generation
people here in the States.
So what do you feel like
you owe to your community?
What is, I don't know, your
North Star in all of this?
And how do you give back?
How often do you visit home?
What is your contribution to
pay back to where you came from?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA: Yeah, I
owe everything to my community,
to my family, to my ancestors
who sacrificed so much.
And if I think I had it bad,
I just think back 60 years.
And I don't know what
they were going through,
but I have a lot of debt.
And I have goals written
down for the next two
years of raising $100,000
for scholarships.
I have an obligation
to make sure
that anybody that wants to go
to school has an opportunity.
I'm actually on the works--
and this is something
that I've been
talking to my friend
Danny Rosenberg
about and Juan and Kelly--
about writing a book
and those proceeds
going to help my community so
that others get opportunities.
But more than that, going out
into the actual communities
and talking to the young
people that have no hope
or don't see people
that look like them.
And so I've been
being more intentional
about doing that, going out
to places where nobody visits.
And that's where the law
of attraction, that's
where it happens.
So I have a friend, Eric
Thomas, that's doing some work.
He does it all over the world.
He invited me to go to
Las Vegas and to really
work with the youth there.
And he said, man, it's some
of the toughest schools
that I've been to
in this country.
And so I'm excited about
that, putting myself
in a pit with a lion on a
snowy day, like the book.
In a pit with a
lion on a snowy day
is putting yourself
in situations
that are uncontrollable.
And do the work, right?
If the person that did NASA
wasn't willing to take risks,
then we wouldn't have that.
So that's how I feel,
as an obligation
to go out and just risk.
And sometimes, maybe things
that haven't been done, just
try them.
And so, again, just
a huge obligation.
And for me, it's education.
That's a pathway out of poverty.
But yeah, I owe
everything I have
to folks that gave
me scholarships,
that gave me opportunities.
KSP paid for my
doctorate degree.
And then there's so many
people that I'm thinking,
like Dr. Tom [? Rios, ?]
Dr. Margie [INAUDIBLE],,
Dr. Hall, that have
been in my life, that
have pushed me to think
bigger, to dream big,
to not settle for anything.
And my wife, too, who always is
on me to do more, to give more.
Give till it hurts, right?
We have a commissioner,
Jesse, who said,
I want to give till it hurts.
And so when you
give, you receive.
And so that's how I felt.
I've been so blessed,
and so I want to give
more than I can give.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Great.
Thank you.
So I would love to start
off the Q&A. Something
that I was thinking
about last night
when preparing for the
talk was, as people who
maybe have a better circumstance
than our parents, ancestors,
grandparents before us, how
do we teach the sense of grit,
the sense of titanium that
you were talking about?
I think that that's
something I wonder, too.
When I get married one day
and maybe have children,
how am I going to
teach that drive?
So you have children of
your own, so I'm wondering,
how do you teach that?
How do you teach that
culture or that ability
to continue no matter what?
And yeah, how do we
pass that forward?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA: Yeah.
So I have four children--
Felipe, Amancio,
Sion, and Eliadio--
and that's what I'm
trying to teach.
Because my father did such a
great job, and like I said,
he'd passed away at 17.
His dad passed away at 17.
And I want to break that chain.
But what my dad did in those
few years that I had him was he
taught me how to
have faith I've never
seen anybody to
have so much faith
and be praying for his family.
And I'm sure sometimes we
didn't know how to eat,
what we were going
to eat the next day,
but he was there praying.
And I'll tell you
something, we never
didn't have food on the table.
I don't know if they
were eating or not.
So that faith.
And that's something
that I teach
my children is to have faith.
And then the work ethic.
You can't expect great results
if you don't put in the work.
So we put them in
martial arts, something
that I didn't have access to.
Like the Y, they also
go to the Y, the camps.
I always tell them,
the only camps
I went with migrant
camps, right,
moving around going
to all these camps,
so you guys get to
go to swimming camp.
And teaching them
the value of that.
Not only do I take
them to the YMCA camps,
but I take them to go
pick strawberries, go
pick blueberries, apples.
They know where
their dad comes from.
They know when they go
and visit their cousins
that they might not get a lot
of gifts still to this day.
They might just get
tamales, and that's OK.
Don't get too high
up there and thinking
that you're so good,
that just because you
get good presents
from us doesn't
mean that when you
go to your place,
you might not get
anything, and that's OK.
So teaching them that
sense of appreciation
for what they have, and
then what they have when
they go out there.
And then more about giving
than just asking for.
And so taking them to
the homeless shelter
and showing them strong
movies that are powerful that
will pierce their soul.
Even at a young age,
those are the things
that I thought about.
And then I have a
band of brothers,
too, that we meet, we
pray, and we talk life.
And I learn from them
how to be a better
father because, again, I don't
have mine here physically.
I have my father-in-law,
who's a great father.
And so those are
the type of things.
If you want to
elevate your game,
you've got to surround
yourself by greatness, right?
And so that's what we try
to do and then pass it
on to the kids.
The question for them is
not, am I going to college?
They're going to college.
Their mom, she's working on
her PhD, my wife, Danielle.
And this morning when they
were doing their prayer,
my wife left to Puerto
Rico this morning.
And they're praying for
her, I hope my mom's good.
And so they're learning
that sense of awareness,
like take care of
people and be good.
So I'm trying my best.
It is very difficult
because I can't simulate
living in the hood
and picking up a fight
just so that I
don't get picked on.
They're not going to
have to live like that.
Or cornflakes with water, they
don't have to worry about that.
We have a refrigerator full
of milk that they can do that.
But as much as I can and telling
them stories, like, look, man,
we grew up poor,
so appreciate it.
And the fact, too,
that I don't have
any pictures from my childhood,
they can't even see that.
I don't know how I
looked when I was little.
And so they have all
kinds of pictures, right?
They're in daycare, they're
already selling you pictures.
We didn't have that.
We couldn't afford that.
It was eating or that picture.
So just teaching
them those things.
That was a long answer.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: Thank you.
FELIPE LOPEZ
SUSTAITA: No problem.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: All right,
we'll open it up for live Q&A
for anyone who would like to.
So we'll have a mic
being passed around.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: First
of all, thank you
for the work you do
for your community.
I think many of ourselves,
many of my colleagues,
myself included, are
from immigrant families.
I'm first generation myself.
I'm curious-- your
work is focused
on lending a voice to those
who might not have channels
to voice their needs.
Personally, how
do you prioritize
the needs of the
communities you're hearing?
You mentioned you're
motivated a lot by the pain,
and I think you probably
measure yourself by the impact
that you're having.
I can imagine that
the impact that you
don't get to have because
you have to choose
causes a lot of pain as well.
But what goes into
your mental calculus,
and how do you decide
which of the issues
you encounter on a daily basis
gets the ears that it deserves?
FELIPE LOPEZ
SUSTAITA: Yes, that's
a very difficult question.
Especially with a very small
budget and a very small staff,
I think we use that
Google approach.
And Daniel will tell
you, we have a board,
a to-do list board.
And it's important.
People don't do it, right?
They don't communicate.
And so we sit there literally
and we spend one or two
hours prioritizing
what's going on,
whether it's a bill
that's being introduced
or whether it's a
community that's in need,
and we evaluate that, and then
we deploy whatever resources
that we have.
So we have to be very
strategic with what we do.
And it always
reminds me of when I
was in school, the same thing.
I had to prioritize and with a
family, always multi-tasking.
But that's how we gauge that.
Because you're right,
there's so many issues.
And right now, with the
current political climate,
it's very difficult. It
could be immigration one day.
It could be bullying
the next day.
It could be an incident that
happened at another community.
And so sometimes
you're in three places
at once, if you didn't
think that's possible.
And we're making a
call and an email
and then physically going there.
So that's how we do it.
And again, I work for God, so
He's guiding me in this work,
and very blessed
to be doing that.
And again, this is
part of it, too.
Having this platform that
Dominique has giving me
the opportunity is so
great because we're
talking to our people
at a larger scale
than I've ever done.
And so this is huge for me.
And so taking the time
to come here and do this
is very important.
But that's how we gauge
and we try to do that.
AUDIENCE: So from traveling
around the state, what's
the current state of Michigan?
If you're meeting
with the governor,
what's the two,
three minute speech
to update him as far as what's
happening in the Michigan
community?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA: Yeah.
And again, it depends when
it is because sometimes it
could be economic or whatever.
So what we did so that
we don't have the two,
three minutes is that we got
a really good team together.
Daniel, he's a researcher,
does all this with numbers.
And then we brought in Jose
Mendez, who was our designer.
And so what we did not
just to do that two minute
or three minute spiel, we
did a whole newsletter,
and we put the issues
there along with a letter,
and then through
communication as well.
So we try to be creative,
almost like Google, man.
Try to put everything
out quickly
because you don't
have time sometimes.
And so I got the
team to do that,
and that has been
very effective.
It's helped us
increase our budget.
It has helped us go
viral in terms of we
got a standalone website
the governor approved.
And there's only
like four or five
departments that
have a similar--
And we had the
staff to do it, too.
And then to make it
into bilingual, too,
so that people that want
to apply for a license
or do something, they
have that access.
So that's how we've done
it through communication
like that, through nice
graphics because we all
know that nice graphics
gets people's attention.
And so we've just been creative.
And when we do have
that time, it's quickly
like, look, you
have this coming,
whatever, whatever,
and we move on.
But we're trying
with what we have.
It's like being a migrant.
You figure it out with a
little time or little money.
AUDIENCE: Hola.
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
I'm trying to frame the
question, but I was curious.
So I moved from Mexico,
born and raised.
I moved two years ago.
And I went through a long
process to get my citizenship,
and I'm still trying to do that.
So I have a lot of
privilege that I
can read and write
in English and afford
a lawyer that helped me out.
And it's been a very
difficult process.
So after all this conversation,
I'm just very curious.
How do these farmer workers get
any help, or any organizations
that help them, too, if they
are aiming to get a citizenship?
How do they get that help?
Is there any ways
for them to get it
if they don't have either
the means or the language
to do that?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA:
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
AUDIENCE: No.
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA:
I'm just kidding.
So yes, there is a
lot of organizations.
And again, we have limited
resources, but we partner
with a lot of great
organizations,
through pro bono lawyers
that have reached out to us.
And we can deploy
resources quickly.
Stuff that's in
Spanish and English,
which sometimes
people don't think.
And then there's people
that can't even speak.
So for us, it's tag teaming.
And if there's a place,
say, for example, farmers,
there's a community of migrants
that can't read or write,
letting that organization
know so that they could deploy
some lawyers that can go in and
kind of answer those questions.
We've also partnered
with a Mexican consulado
and done some work
with them as well
to send them to the
community so that they could
get their passport
because some of them
can't go, or get
registrations or whatever.
So it's all about
using what you have
and then putting things
in place to make it work.
So that's some of the
work that we're doing.
So I'm so happy.
So you work for Google?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
FELIPE LOPEZ
SUSTAITA: Man, great.
You guys, we're all
over the place, right?
DOMINIQUE EHRL: All right,
so we're almost out of time.
Probably have time for one
more question, if there is one.
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA:
Any burning questions.
Oh, we got one.
AUDIENCE: First of all, thank
you for sharing your story.
I think it was really
touching and impressive how
you managed to break the cycle.
I think that's kind
of the key over here.
So my question is--
I mean, you were
like a lot of us.
We're lucky to
have like a mentor
or to run into
people that actually
made a difference in our lives.
How do you say that can
be scalable, for example,
if you just don't
have the opportunities
and you just don't happen
to step into someone that
is willing to help you look?
How can we actually
make that a bigger plan?
FELIPE LOPEZ SUSTAITA: Yeah,
that's a good question.
And I think we all
need mentors, right?
But if you're not
in those spaces,
you don't get those
opportunities.
So what I would say
is that we need--
because now we're all here,
we're in a place of privilege,
we are mentors, whether
we see it or not.
So for me, it's just
taking it to the next step.
If my wife gave me permission
to go to Las Vegas for four days
to work with those kids
and going where they are--
because there's no way
they'll ever get to me,
and I'm not even a
big deal or anything--
but I can go and maybe
share some positivity, then
I'm willing to do that,
whether it's there
or whether it's going to
Central America or wherever.
Shoot, we were in Africa,
and I learned so much
from those folks.
But some people
can get out, right?
They don't have the access
or the privilege to do that.
So I just think that us--
we have a responsibility
to go out and do that work
and be intentional about it.
Yeah, because everybody
needs somebody.
I think none of us
in this room would
have been here if we didn't
have access to somebody
that believed in us.
And so it's
critically important.
So, yeah.
So for me, it's just going out
and doing it more, and more
intentional with a mission.
And that's something that
I do, too-- to close this--
that has helped, for
me, going out sometimes,
and I go and speak
and I offer to mentor.
So I go and I have mentees,
and I wake up at 6:00 AM.
I do that pledge
to wake up at 6:00
AM with MSU college students.
And I walk during the
entire school year.
And then I tell them,
the whole purpose of this
is to build an army.
So I'm going to mentor
you, I'm committing
that two hours or that whole
semester one hour each week.
And then I expect for you to
go back and mentor two people
next year when you come.
And that's how you
build an army, right?
So intentionally they're
going out and seeking that.
So those are just some
strategies that I've used.
And so thank you
for that question.
DOMINIQUE EHRL: I
just want to echo
that, just going into
communities with intention.
And then I think secondly,
meeting people where they are.
There's sometimes
this false expectation
that people are just
going to naturally
be interested to speak to
all of us, which I really
think is false.
And we have to be more aware and
more willing to sometimes also
take off our Google
hats and come in
as people, approach people
as Latinos, as Asians,
as black people, as
whatever your identity is,
to better connect and
maybe break through
to someone who might need it.
So thank you so much, Felipe.
Thank you for joining
us at Google today.
It was a pleasure.
And really appreciate your
authenticity and vulnerability
to share your story.
So thank you so much for coming.
A round of applause
for Dr. Felipe.
[APPLAUSE]